usa la recta numérica para comprar 11.5
y 11.7
entonces empezamos por pintar nuestra
recta numérica
y como estos dos números están entre 11
y 12 entonces nos vamos a fijar en ese
pedazo de la recta numérica aquí está el
número 11 por aquí está el número 12 y
pues vamos a dividir nuestra recta
numérica entre el 11 y el 12 en 10
pedacitos que representan a los
decimales que entonces podemos empezar
por calcular le más o menos aquí es la
mitad
y bueno obviamente esta no es una
división exacta de la recta numérica en
diez pedacitos en diez decimales porque
pues lo hice a mano y pues no son
distancias exactas pero son una muy
buena aproximación entonces saber
empezamos en once enteros y todos estos
son decimales entonces este es el 11.1
11.2 11.3 11.4
este es el 11.5 que es uno de los
números que queremos entonces este es el
11.5
y este es el 11.6 11.7 este es el otro
11.7 y bueno nada más para terminar de
ver los decimales
este es el 11.8 11.9 y pues obviamente
ya no es el 11.10 porque ese sería como
el 11.1 este es el 12 y por la forma en
la que dibujamos esta recta numérica
conforme nos vamos moviendo a la derecha
van aumentando los números osea el 11 es
más chico que el 12 el 11.5 es más chico
que el 11.6 que es más chico que el 11.7
entonces el 11.7 es mayor que el 11.5 a
ver no si quiere escribir la desigualdad
al revés 11.5 es menor que 11.7 entonces
cuál es el mayor mayores 11.7 osea el
mayor es este
11.7